k2tog, psso ssk, yo.
These terms may be mysterious to you, but
as a machine knitter, if you want to use
hand knitting patterns, it's critical that
you understand what these terms mean and
you're able to translate them
to machine knitting techniques.
The concept of deliberately
making holes in your knitting.
Also known as lace, is the same no matter
whether you're using two sticks or a
knitting machine.
We'll talk about three common knitting
techniques and how to work them on the
machine.
First, if you're lucky enough to have
a standard gauge machine with a lace
carriage, the lace carriage will
make all the transfers for you.
But it's important that you understand
what's happening between your patterning
device, punch card or electronics and the
needles on the needle bed and the lace
carriage.
Let's look at how lace works on all
machines, no matter how the needles are
selected or transferred.
First is a yarn over, also known
as an eyelet on the machine.
Anytime you have an empty needle and work
and you knit across the row, the working
yarn will travel over that needle.
When you knit the next row, that strand
becomes a stitch and you have an eyelet.
Now, to empty the needle, you need to
knit two stitches together somehow.
Have you heard the term right-leaning
decrease in the left leaning decrease?
This refers to both the position of the
decreased stitch in relation to the yarn
over and the direction it's leaning
or the direction it was transferred.
In hand knitting, we refer to knit two
together as a right leaning decrease.
Slip, slip knit or SSK as
a left leaning decrease.
When you're hand knitting, these depend
on how you insert your needle into the
stitches and form the decreased stitch.
Also in hand, that end, you're looking at
your knitting from the right side, public
side or the knit side of the work.
So left and right
leaning makes some sense.
But for machine knitters, the purl side of
the knitting is facing us, so we have to
think a little backwards.
Picture this, use a transfer tool
and remove a stitch from its needle.
Transfer that stitch over to its neighbor.
Either right or left it doesn't matter.
Okay.
Look closely and the
stitch you transferred.
Remember we worked from the purl side.
That stitch is hiding behind
the stitch next to it.
This would be like a yarn over,
then the two together in hand knitting.
We'll examine why this
matters in a minute.
Now, if you're getting a little
overwhelmed, hang in there with me.
Let's for now, let's take a look at
a two-step machine knitting transfer.
This time we'll first transfer stitch and
then move both of those stitches to the
empty needle to reposition
the upcoming yarn over.
So when you knit the next row and these
two stitches are knit and we look from the
knit side of the knitting, notice that the
front facing stitch is really defined and
it's leaning to the right.
This would be the equivalent of an SSK,
yarn over sequence for hand knitters.
Now, why does this matter?
In this sample I used the
simple one-step transfer method.
First I transferred, right,
and then I transferred left.
In this sample, I used the two-step
transfer method, and you can see the more
defined stitch pattern.
Looking at more complex lace patterns.
You can see how this
does make a difference.
Okay, so it's the direction of the stitch
transfer in relation to the position of
the eyelet or that yarn over that
determines the appearance of any lace
sequence.
The best way to really understand these
concepts and apply them to creating your
own lace patterns with electronics or
punch cards or even hand manipulation is
to try them.
Happy knitting.